for the last month i have been wearing
every single piece of trash that i
create why the average u.s american
creates nearly five pounds of trash per
day i wanted to see what that would look
like every single piece of trash that i
create goes into the suit and i wear it
everywhere that i go and recycling that
goes in too because most recyclables
aren't actually recycled let's see what
kind of trouble i get into
this was specially designed by a woman
named nancy judd she specializes in
trashion which is trash fashion so this
suit was designed to be able to hold up
to 135 pounds of trash because that's
what the average u.s american creates in
a month the suit is designed to be
expandable to grow as the trash grows so
i'm going to go ahead and weigh in i was
153.7 pounds
and now with the suit it's 164.2
so this suit weighs 10 and a half pounds
all right so it's time to add the first
trash
this is all of the trash that was
created in making the suit i just
weighed it and it's about three pounds
and lastly the scale that i had to use
to weigh myself
this is a little scary because i've just
gotten started and i've already got five
pounds of garbage on me and i'm not sure
what's gonna happen
[Music]
so i'm less than 24 hours in and i have
to say i'm actually blown away by the
amount of trash that i've created and
i'm not even trying to create trash i'm
just walking through society
following along what other people are
doing
[Music]
i'm here in hollywood california because
i want to inspire and influence the rich
and the famous to rethink their waste am
i allowed to come in and buy something
nothing's leaking right
no have any questions pretty interesting
i'm living like the average american for
a month but i'm wearing every piece of
trash that i create
no more landfills that'd be great
hey there
how are you
good i'll have a frappuccino
trash man
[Music]
what do you do with toilet paper
so toilet paper goes down the toilet as
usual what do you do with recycling the
recycling also goes into the trash suit
because
most of our recycling doesn't actually
recycle did i take a photo
[Music]
[Music]
normally you would never find me at a
mcdonald's or creating all of this trash
or living this consumeristic life i eat
mostly unpackaged unprocessed foods i
grow some of my own food i forage food
from the land in fact i even did a year
where i grew and foraged everything that
i ate but right now you find me at
mcdonald's because it's the most popular
restaurant i think in the entire world
so it really represents consumerism i
really believe
that this visual will catch people
and really wake them up i was dreading
the burger but
it's not as bad as i was expecting
actually my goal is not to be a smelly
example but a visual example of our
waist so i wash everything before i add
it to the suit and for food waste
i weigh that and then i replace it with
bags of dry rice it's the end of day six
and i am overwhelmed with the trash that
i've created i took it all out of the
suit in order to clean it and i am just
i'm just boggled this is six days worth
of living like the average person and
i've already created about 20 pounds of
trash which is actually
substantially less than the average
person would have made in this time
can't believe that i have another 24
days
[Music]
all right so i'm out in hollywood and
i'm gonna see if i can get into a club
am i allowed in
how come
i'm gonna try to get into chateau
marmont which is one of hollywood's most
iconic celebrity hot spots i was
checking to see if the hotel bar is
still open
it's closed
okay cool
all right it's too exclusive they didn't
even give me the time of day or have any
understanding of what i am doing so
no luck there
i'm about to try to get into the viper
room which i've been told is like one of
the fanciest most exclusive clubs so i
walked up and the bouncer absolutely
loved what i was doing in fact she
wanted to take a picture of me at her
door so i thought i'm definitely getting
in a little blown away after all that
rejected i'm going to give it one last
try before calling in a night
hey
how's it going
so i'm living like the average consumer
for a month and i'm wearing all the
trash i create so i was wondering if i
can come in
okay sweet thanks
[Music]
all right there's one place that
accepted the trash band that was a
success had some conversations inside
the bar and even did a little dancing
you know for most people trash is out of
sight out of mind they never have to
think about it it's just kind of ironic
that i'm just a walking billboard of
what they're doing
and then simply by taking responsibility
for my trash and holding on to it
they don't allow me to come inside
[Music]
just kidding i don't actually sleep in
my trash it's day 13
and i am very tired
and very much struggling
i
feel super disconnected from
nature
and
i
am craving some healthy food i have not
been eating nearly as much vegetables as
i'm used to the suit is getting heavy
i'm up to
34 pounds there's definitely an element
of like how am i gonna get through this
[Music]
i am signing up for an exclusive dating
app for
influencers i read online that only
about eight percent of people get
accepted all right name
trash man actually i might need to put
my real name to get accepted enter your
instagram
what do i do for work
um
inspire
positive
change
oh too many characters
all right
i'll put activist okay we will notify
you regarding your application via push
notification we'll see if i'm exclusive
enough
and we'll see if any
one wants to date the trash man so i
didn't have any luck with the online
dating apps and raya no responses no
messages but i do have a date lined up
it's a friend who set it up for me her
name's jess and we're meeting for ice
cream i'm actually a little nervous
right now
we'll see how this goes hello
[Laughter]
so have you ever been on a date with a
trash man
well i mean
yes
okay well i'm trashy on the outside but
i'm not trashy on the inside oh i mean
we'll find out right
i will say that i have felt a little
trapped over the last days you know
imagine this is the trash suit for one
person i know oh god imagine the trash
suit for the entire human race people
aren't thinking about this it is
unconscious so what's your zero waste
catering it mostly is on sets because
like that's like my background how do
you approach relationships which is
gung-ho what are you looking for so
relationships are tricky because i do a
lot of extreme activism and i travel a
lot because my way of life is relatively
extreme i haven't been in a relationship
for four years i've designed my life to
be relatively
unattached
there's not many things that i commit to
long term want to help me up
oh god
i got you here
all right well it's been a great day
yeah
the date was good we had some nice deep
conversation we talked about the trash
suit but we talked about a lot of other
things as well
and i would definitely go on a second
date with jess i would go on a second
date much more to explore
los angeles is a place where people come
to make it there are so many people out
here just trying to get in front of the
cameras promoting themselves that's
ultimately what i'm doing out here as
well trying to figure out ways to break
in to get on the media to connect with
celebrities that have influence and i
have to say it really doesn't feel
good i'm trying to promote an actual
message for me it's a balance between
spreading this message and making sure
to not get too caught up in the rat race
of it all
the scale reads
218.4 pounds and that means i am wearing
54 pounds of trash less than i was
expecting but it is still overwhelming
so we're about to show up at craigs
which is one of the fanciest restaurants
in hollywood and i'm here because the
paparazzi is waiting outside for
celebrities so i'm gonna roll up and see
if i can't get the attention of the
paparazzi
good evening everyone
good evening
so amazingly that was a huge success i
have to say that hollywood has totally
embraced the trash man and that i've
become a fun but awakening part of the
culture out here this morning i woke up
and
my neck my upper back
is in a pretty bad place i don't really
know how i could do this for another
like nine days i would say maybe some
people would call it
injured i think the reason why is
because i decided to ride this bull last
night at a bar and that was just a bad
idea
normally i live a near zero waste life
and most of what you see here
is single use items in plastics and
these can be avoided by carrying our own
reusables we can also shop unpackaged
for our food we can buy items secondhand
rather than new and one of the biggest
ones is composting
my trip to los angeles has been a
success i've come out here and i've put
trash in people's face and gotten people
to really think about the truth behind
our trash and how we can live
differently on this earth the campaign
was covered by hundreds of media outlets
all over the world i'm jada monterreno
here with rob greenfield can i give you
a trash
[Music]
all right it's time for the final
weigh-in
i just weighed myself and i'm at 155
pounds which is about the same as i
started with i am up to 238
pounds with the trash suit on so that
means that the total weight of the trash
is 72 pounds that is about two and a
half pounds of trash per day and the
average person creates closer to five
pounds of trash per day so what you see
here is actually half as much trash as
the average person creates by weight
which is
absolutely astounding because
just look at this the idea is to look at
this and say is that what my trash suit
would look like
what do you think
[Music]
you